so help me understand like what are the
missing functionalities
uh or features that uh you would expect
to see
in a true crypto prime brokerage that
aren't there today but would
have a significant impact or create an
inflection point for you guys in the way
that you would want to trade
yeah so a lot of this also has to do
with the fact that we are a u.s
company right so many people when they
want to
go long or short they'll go on some of
these international exchanges
that are unregulated in the u.s so call
it like the bit max or
ftx's of the world and they'll they'll
trade there
we're a us onshore entity investment
manager so we
we have excluded ourselves from those
venues so
um when we want to short the market we
have to go and borrow coin and then sell
it
and then rebuy it and return the loan so
it's just logistically complicated so
what what we need to see and what this
space needs to see is a prime broker
that allows
for spot trading so being able to buy
and sell uh
traditional coin and that allows for
shorting the markets being able to
facilitate all the the borrowing
uh that you need to do to short the
market all within one platform
and provide all of that with apis so
that it can be done electronically
and it's missing like i think a lot of
that has to do with the regulatory
work that's required as uh to serve u.s
customers like i think it's just
that there's too much there's too much
regulation today
in the us that makes it cumbersome for
those companies to go through the effort
not knowing if they're actually going to
materially see
business show up and once they they've
gone through all that compliance work so
uh like the pieces are starting to be
there and you're seeing companies kind
of begin to focus on it certainly prime
brokerage has been the hot topic
over the last 60 days in this space
you've seen a number of acquisitions
or announcements between coinbase and
bitco and genesis i'm all sort of
focusing on that area but there's still
a lot of work to
happen yeah it's really interesting too
because it feels like
people know that this stuff needs to
exist it's just everyone's looking
around the room like hey who's going to
build it
uh and some of that is time right and
some of it is
uh the large companies will eventually
add some of that you see coinbase kind
of acquire
to gomi um and kind of full disclosure
we were an investor there
but then you also see a lot of kind of
building in-house
large companies especially the
international ones you mentioned
but do you think that uh the funds in
the space
can ultimately get their heads around
trusting new
startups or kind of challengers in the
space so you know somebody shows up
they raise a couple million bucks and
they say hey look uh we've built x y or
z
uh functionality that you just described
but they don't come
with uh the insurance or the big brand
name
or the you know couple years of track
record or history
like what does that look like from a
trust standpoint with funds that are
managing
you know millions if not hundreds of
millions of dollars yeah
it's also it's also a liquidity problems
you've got all the issues you described
and then you've got the liquidity
problem so
anybody that's actively trading in this
space they're going to go to where the
liquidity resides and so that the
startups that exist and we've seen this
like
exchanges in 2019 that was the hottest
thing and there were new exchanges all
the time
they all had different features and
functions that
that they felt were going to really
differentiate themselves but none of
them had liquidity
liquidity begets liquidity like people
go where where they can trade
and so so that's a big challenge i i
think part of me
has been wondering about this for the
last couple months like i'm more
concerned about where the customers are
like the tagumi piece is a fascinating
one to me because you had a pretty
killer
team and they raised 27 million dollars
in funding
at a pretty high valuation um like they
built the product itself
was good again kind of lacking some of
that the liquidity
and lacking some of the lending side but
like structurally the product was
was pretty good but at the end of the
day i i don't think
that they saw enough revenue being
walking through the door from from
customers to sort of be able to go raise
that next
round and that's that's part of the
problem like you look at this space
2017 2018 2019 a lot of great teams
raised a lot of money at very high
valuations
and that forces sort of the next
valuation the next raise to be
to be really high and you've got to have
revenue to support that and i don't i
don't know
if the revenue is here yet for that many
companies to be able to support the next
round so
2020 2021 to me will be pretty
fascinating
i think you're going to see sort of the
the cream rise to the top
and companies like block high who have
been able to do phenomenal things with
the capital they've raised and really
grow
customers like drive revenue like those
types of companies that they're going to
do very well
but people who have sort of built either
copycat businesses or things
that don't really differentiate in a
meaningful way i think you're gonna have
a really hard time kind of continuing to
fund their business what happens there
do they die or is there just
consolidation from like an m
a front i think we're gonna see both
right i think
that the really good teams and i think
tagoma is a great example right there's
a good team good
product you build you bring that inside
of somebody else that has the
the legs to support it and to help that
grow
i think you'll see that type of
acquisition play out
i mean it really it it reminds me of the
cloud computing space
when i was there with the last business
like that the teams that raised too much
money they got
bought and incorporated to companies
like red hat and cisco and
uh and sort of trying to help steer
direction inside of those bigger
companies
i think you're going to see the same
thing here and so companies like
fidelity who are building their own
things internally like that's going to
be great
then the sort of the tier 2 banks are
going to realize okay we're late
we're late and we don't have time to go
build how do we go pick up the teams
that know what they're doing
how do we pick up the the companies that
have built functional
products and and kind of fill the voids
that we have internally
and so this this bill versus buy
question
i think is going to play out in a
material way it's just it's just a
matter of what sort of at what point
does this become
such a critical need at each one of
these institutions that
that they realize they're late